[Musica]
ottimi ottimi presentatori a rompere
l'imbarazzo
Ciao sono Nicola ho 21 anni nella vita
faccio il content Creator E ogni tanto
studio ingegneria Insomma quando capita
un pensiero molto razionale e ho questa
grande tendenza a cercare di capire ciò
che mi affascina e interpretarlo in
maniera quasi scientifica come se
dovesse essere inequivocabile per me e
per tutti gli altri
c'è una cosa durante la mia giovane vita
che mi ha sempre affascinato sia le
emozioni
Ecco le emozioni che per definizione Si
distaccano molto dalla razionalità sono
complicate Da analizzare in parzialmente
molto difficile associarle a un origine
fisica o a una causa fisiologica sono
subitanea irrompenti imprevedibili e la
consapevolezza delle stesse non implica
che sappiamo come gestirle cioè sappiamo
cosa fare se ci siamo rotti una gamba ad
esempio ma non abbiamo delle vere e
proprie linee guida se stiamo soffrendo
per amore o se abbiamo paura di qualcosa
dobbiamo rassegnarci al fatto che certe
cose
non le capiamo o che comunque anche
capendole con un certo grado di vaghezza
non sempre e non necessariamente
sappiamo come intervenire
per mia fortuna ho compreso dai miei
esami passati che non sempre alla fine
serve capire le cose alla radice per
saperle usare A volte basta sperimentare
vedere quale causa porta un determinato
effetto Come fanno gli scienziati
giocare come fa un neonato che vede un
oggetto attraente comincia a speculare
sul suo comportamento
Ora io non mi permetterei mai di giocare
con le emozioni degli altri chiaramente
ma ho spesso giocato con le mie Ho
provato diverse cose la paura di fallire
la gioia del valere lo strazio del
sacrificio e qualche signorino qua
direbbe che questo vuol dire
semplicemente maturare
quel signorino ha ragione
ma poi ho voluto traslare questo mio
sperimentare in una dimensione più
interpersonale ho voluto vedere le
persone che emozioni provassero da certi
stimoli
stimolo stimola un'azione particolare è
un'azione che ha una peculiarità indica
il fatto che il soggetto il soggetto che
lo subisce sia passivo non stia facendo
nulla attivamente per ricevere lo
stimolo non è detto che sia pronto o che
ipotizzi la ricezione
Paradossalmente una persona può ricevere
uno stimolo anche se immersa nella noia
noia
ora forse per dirla in una frase il
motivo per cui sono qua è perché ci sono
persone che ritengono io sia Bravo
nell'ottenere l'attenzione e sicuramente
ci ho lavorato per capire come ottenere
l'attenzione dalle persone ma per
cominciare a farlo Sono partito da lei
dalla noia
la noia è una cosa astratta è difficile
da classificare si potrebbe argomentare
che la noia sia lei stessa Un emozione
Ma per come l'ho interpretata io la noia
è l'assenza di variazione nelle emozioni
e la persistente presenza di una singola
sensazione nella nostra sfera emotiva
correggetemi se sbaglio ma qua a quanto
pare nessuno piace la noia cerchiamo
costantemente per quanto possibile di
trovare impulsi nella nostra vita
stimoli come vi ho detto prima Cerchiamo
sempre la prossima cosa a cui dare
attenzione
il concetto che si è sviluppato in me
quando stavo cercando di capire come
ottenere l'attenzione dalle persone è
stato ciò che io chiamo
altalena di emozioni
di per sé un'altalena è divertente No da
bambino da ragazzo magari anche per
qualche adulto nostalgico Se però
pensiamo a questa altalena come un giro
intenso in quelle che sono sensazioni
che stimolano la nostra voglia di capire
L'emozione che c'è dopo allora lì il
gioco è fatto
avete capito niente vero Vabbè mi spiego
meglio non so se avete mai pensato a
come un intrattenitore sia capace di
rubare subdolamente la vostra attenzione
ma sicuramente concorderete sul fatto
che se qualcuno vi sta intrattenendo
Siete sempre propensi ad ascoltare cosa
viene dopo la sorpresa che c'è dopo la
notizia la battuta il dramma la
situazione il gesto La dote il talento
Se ci pensate gli intrattenitori vi
fanno fare un giro in un altalena Un
comico è capace di comunicarvi con
assoluta risolutezza in imbarazzo per
poi dopo percorrere sequenzialmente
aggressività infine ironia vi dà una
spinta in questa altalena di emozioni
dove partita con dubbio Magari curiosità
continuate con ansia e finite con gioia
un'intrattenitore è eccellente nel
creare un'aspettativa per poi dopo
superarla o perché no
rappresenta totalmente e noi spesso non
ci chiediamo nemmeno perché continuiamo
a dondolare in questa altalena però ci
piace stiamo giocando siamo intrattenuti
è semplicemente piacevole in questa
altalena abbiamo oscillazioni più forti
e più deboli a volte abbiamo paura altre
volte siamo solo scettici dipende dalla
forza con cui l'intrattenitore decide di
spingerci a volte diffidiamo da questo
intrattenitore e ci stringiamo forti
alle funi per non rischiare di cadere
altre volte crediamo ciecamente in chi
ci spinge e non abbiamo il minimo
pensiero di soffrire per questo gioco
Anzi ci piace saltare a mezz'aria A fine
corsa e ridere vigorosamente con un
accenno di rappresentanza o perché no di
protagonismo
ora immagini immaginate la medesima cosa
su Tik Tok dove l'intrattenitore ha
mediamente 8 secondi per attirare
l'attenzione dello spettatore ma in
realtà molto di meno questo è ciò questo
lavorando negli ultimi due anni della
mia vita come Creator di video di forma
breve spesso questa dimensione di
intrattenimento viene svalutata anche se
in realtà non è di banale comprensione
come si faccia a sgomitare ed emergere
tra tutti i Creator e la verità è che
abbiamo pochi secondi per questa volta
ci ritroviamo a spiegare poco e dire
tanto
ci ritroviamo a lasciare intendere e non
far capire alcuni provocano urlano o
raccontano senza preambolo proprio
perché abbiamo pochi secondi ci
ritroviamo sia a farti capire cosa
vogliamo fare
ma non te lo mostriamo fino alla fine
del video perché la tua attenzione è una
cosa preziosa e noi cerchiamo di
conservarla con gelosia finché è
possibile la forma di intrattenimento
inclinata in questa maniera per me ha
creato quelli che io chiamo artisti
dell'attenzione
i creatorterni su Tik Tok Hills YouTube
shorts sono artisti dell'attenzione Io
li vedo come giovani ma in realtà non
solo giovani
che usano uno strumento che ancora deve
essere costruito bene ma intanto stanno
capendo Come funziona o come in teoria
dovrebbe funzionare alcuni diciamocelo
padroneggiano l'attenzione perché hanno
un'apparenza ammaliante altri si sono
inventati metodi comunicativi assurdi
per cercare di trasportarti nel loro
discorso molti sono eccellenti nel farti
ridere altrettanti coloro che cercano di
insegnarti pillole della loro vita
circa sei anni fa gli intrattenitori del
web erano capaci di creare una sorta di
intimità con lo spettatore
perché perché non c'era fretta
nell'ottenere l'attenzione le cose erano
più lente era un'altalena che dondolava
dolcemente in campagna e
l'intrattenitore era capace di
raccontarti la sua vita mentre tu andavi
avanti e indietro oggi l'altalena è
frenetica è una giostra automatizzata in
centro città dove un giro dura
mediamente 20 secondi e siccome Oggi più
che mai ciò che vediamo hai deciso in
buona parte da un algoritmo gli artisti
dell'attenzione hanno fuso suoni balli
parole animazioni sorpresa con la loro
disciplina preferita informazione Sport
commedia cucina tutto ciò Solo per
rendere l'altalena più frenetica e farla
eccellere tra le tante
Ognuno di loro si ingegna per trovare un
modo di intromettersi nel traffico una
comunicazione che vinca e che
intrattenga e la cosa essenziale nella
ricerca di questa comunicazione è sempre
quella
non avere paura di andare controcorrente
nel momento in cui uscite dalla vostra
comfort zone dovete essere convinti
perché la vostra convinzione sarà
un'emozione forte che saprà dare una
bellissima spinta al vostro spettatore
detto ciò spero sussista in voi
quotidianamente la voglia di dondolare
la voglia di apprezzare chi ci spinge e
capire come è fatta l'altalena di
costruito che ha costruito e oltre a ciò
spero sia stato dolce il dondolare negli
ultimi 10 minuti passati al seme
perché farvi cadere non è mai stato il
mio obiettivo Grazie
bravo